it's time for roses and Rosie with love
connections I'm gonna take these glasses
off because I'm already impaired tonight
we're going to drink every time someone
says something incredibly uncomfortable
and I demand over here ah credibly
uncomfortable so we need Josh and Amanda
we're getting together but now we have
Josh loves pizza I want to focus on the
important things in life yeah Josh
really loves pizza
Josh also loves to sweat you know how
sweaty I am I think he might have the
cheese sweats
that's a real thing but I don't know if
we're gonna get through a single episode
of the season without bringing up Josh
and his ex Andi Dorfman and her book
what a love triangle am i right
Evan was bringing up the fictional story
that my ex has written about me and
trying to make me look bad in front of
Amanda I guess so this week Evan
confronted Josh about it and Josh is
very intimidating what's ever several
big brother yeah I thought like Evan was
being dragged off by the Mafia there but
then Evan waxed poetic and prove that
the pen is mightier than the sword with
this phrase there's an ocean of words
but there's no thoughts powerful words
and they made sense cuz what Josh says
isn't making sense as much as there is
to say or could be to save but jury's
still out on Josh you know everybody's
warning Amanda about him but he hasn't
actually done anything that wrong other
than sweat oh this is hot I love
connection that we thought might be over
but apparently is not Carly in heaven
I've got a new lease on love so I'm
gonna pee to stay there you got to get a
rose and Carly gave Evan her rose she
called it a platonic rose definitely a
platonic rose she also didn't have
anyone else to give the rose to now we
come to our first awkward phrase of the
night
I haven't closed the door on Carly
she may have closed the door on me but
accidentally forgot to lock it
so maybe I can sneak back in no you
don't want to pick the lock in and go in
that's a crime
you're the sirens that's Evans medical
emergency so Evan had this weird medical
situation that he seemed to be faking
but Carly said if he was faking it she'd
be really upset really mad and Carly
like spent the night laying next to him
to take care of him but she didn't want
to kiss him or anything hey Bert Eber
excellent efore Evan but Evan quit being
rude so maybe I can sneak back in oh my
god it's Kayla Kayla joined the cast
night you guys Kayla from Ben's season
and she walked in and here's the thing I
have always loved Kayla's hair it's
beautiful she's like a Disney Princess
but then Nick said this she has
fantastic hair unbelievable like I just
wanna learn that can I wash your shampoo
your hair oh I gotta give the twins
credit for just being sound bite
machines I mean the crap they say
Brandon didn't even notice when we
switched and I think that's like a
really big deal I literally can't wait
to kiss his face again sometimes it
comes off as condescending
I don't know what is condescending me
then the Fantastic Four gone the first
double date in paradise paradise history
and spend the whole day complimenting
each other and their relationships I
just really got four of us connected
immediately and then they go to a phone
party and I didn't see Venus looking
good
remember him on The Bachelorette
different person also he shaved his back
now just like jury's still out on Josh
jury's still out on Kayla
all the ladies seem to think that she's
a backstabbing [ __ ] but she actually
seems really nice maybe a little cheesy
she says stuff like this she ever feel
like you can just like leave all this
behind and never look back
leave what oh behind you're in paradise
and at the end of the episode we had the
return of a fan favorite the ashley i of
the storm hits Ashley I can't believe
how much this girl cries tell me that
yeah we see them teaser for next week
she already cries and she said that
Jarrod sends her roses but they never
had sex she's been in love with him for
a year why did she share that they never
had sex I came I just a lot to say I
don't know it's all happening Tuesday
night on bachelor in paradise I will be
watching tweet me your thoughts and be
sure to subscribe to ET on youtube to
keep watching all the bachelor nation
shows you can't take it with you you
know you can take with you crabs be
careful and paradise everybody it's true